you can't wear a concert if you would
like us to do a violin freestyle rap for
you
you're very welcome I'll make sure we're
a safe distance that we don't risk
infection singing anyone amando is an
amazing violinist I am a freestyle rap
in the UK whatever you want to hear a
rap about I will then do that and let
the Dodgers their the yet good I'm not
from there being positive being positive
police community engagement the Dodgers
and one final one I might know do you
want to drop a beat and let's let's do
this
[Music]
the best strings the best rinds he got
an offer for these officers I'm offering
the Dodgers and seeing them in the
stadium I try some knockout the park
when I'm running around the diamond
first base second base third base fourth
oh I've got the strength that could
kicked like a horse I can pitch catch it
in the global push comes to shove when
I'm rappin bout baseball don't know
enough so I gotta make the more kinda
generic things I'm hoping the next month
brings and then to this gal of inside
cuz we're so bored of coronavirus hoping
that the quarry team breaks his curse
and we can go outside and never rehearse
I always make it up yeah right off of
from this kid clever with the Rams when
I'm keeping it positive
I like this nice look that's the
flattery I'm positive like the end of a
battery you can see me yeah it's a
clever kid what's the opposite of
positive that's negative we don't need
that with impunity I drop bars and
police the community admittedly that's
not what I do it's not the job of me is
the job of you and you to keep it
positive round this block
everybody's like it's our favorite cops
top intact if they wear one they were
amazed I like the one of you is wearing
the shades one of them a mirror one of
them is matte one of them is metallic
blue one of them is black but wearing
them yeah you look real fly I can't wear
shades cuz it hurts my eyes
[Music]
thank you so much how scary is it
working for people with guns remember I
can a not internet it's scary because in
the country illegally